[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer
außergewöhnlichen sternstunde mir
gegenüber sitzt der ehemalige us
vizepräsident und
friedensnobelpreisträger al gore am
diesjährigen zurich film festival
präsentiert er die fortsetzung seines
oscar gekrönten films eine unangenehme
wahrheit seine lebensaufgabe ist nach
wie vor der kampf gegen den klimawandel
vielleicht die größte herausforderung
vor der die menschheit je gestanden hat
und die zeit rennt auch für uns beide
denn wir haben nur eine halbe stunde
legen wir also los herzlich willkommen
ergo danke ja sie haben als sie in das
weiße haus gezogen sind haben sie sich
eine große fotografie über das pult
gehängt und zwar ein bild der erde vom
weltraum aus gesehen und dieses bild
wird eine wichtige rolle für sie für
ihren film oder ihre filme und auch für
ihre vorträge die sie überall in der
ganzen welt halten
was löst dieses bild der erde bei ihnen
aus
[Musik]
hat die natur für sie ein wert an sich
also ist sie um ihrer selbst willen
schützenswert oder geht es ihnen eher um
eine frage der gerechtigkeit im
umweltschutz das heißt um zukünftige
generation also letztlich um den
menschen
sie beschäftigen sich seit 40 jahren mit
dem klimawandel und haben dazu
beigetragen dass viele
wissenschaftlichen fakten ins
öffentliche bewusstsein getreten sind
etwa dass der menschliche co2 ausstoß
maßgeblich zum 3 basiseffekt und zur
erderwärmung beiträgt dass dadurch die
polkappen schmelzen die gletscher der
meeresspiegel steigt und wie wir seit
ein paar wochen und monaten immer mehr
sehen auch die wetter- extreme zu nehmen
können sie sich noch an den moment
erinnern als ihnen klar wurde dieses
problem ist vielleicht das größte für
die menschheit insgesamt und sie wollen
ihr leben dafür einsetzen um dieses
problem zu lösen
was hat das ausgelöst
[Musik]
nicht zufrieden wie sie langsam dass
vorwärts geht und sie bezeichnen es auch
aus ihr persönliches versagen und wir
schauen uns aus ihrem neuen film eine
unangenehme fortsetzung einen kurzen
ausschnitt
wir sehen mit wie viel herz
dabei sind
[Musik]
ftd s
im unterschied zu anderen sozialen
bewegungen bürgerrechtsbewegungen geht
es beim klimawandel irgendwie darum auch
eine stimme einzuholen die noch nicht da
ist das heißt diejenigen die am
stärksten betroffen sind sind die
zukünftigen generationen und die haben
noch keine stimme
wie muss die politik mit diesem problem
umgehen
[Musik]
aber sie sagen die wahrheit hat es heute
schwer denn die demokratie sei gehackt
worden sei
was meinen sie damit
[Musik]
beim klimawandel fragt sich jeder von
uns auch was kann ich persönlich dazu
beitragen dass die temperatur nicht
weiter steigt und eines davon ist zum
beispiel weniger fleisch zu essen das
weiß man
oder weniger zu fliegen sie selbst leben
soweit ich weiss vegan seit einigen
jahren wahrscheinlich aus ökologischen
gründen nehme ich an
wäre es nicht auch zusätzlich zu einer
co2 steuer die sie fordern ein probates
mittel so etwas wie eine fleisch steuer
zu fordern
aber beim fliegen wenn ich fragen würden
sie sagen jeder kann so viel fliegen wir
möchten wir das kompensieren oder wird
sie sagen da müssen wir auf bestimmte
standards verzichten
[Musik]
bei der vorbereitung hat mich überrascht
zu lesen dass die kinder den größten
einfluss auf das klima haben also eigene
kinder
wer kein auto hat spart 24 tonnen co2
pro jahr
wer dagegen kein kind hat spart fast 60
tonnen co2 pro jahr
sie haben vier kinder müssten nicht
sagen macht weniger kinder
[Musik]
ist denn die sache noch realistisch muss
sich jetzt fragen also ist es noch nicht
zu spät überhaupt die wende zu schaffen
und die klimakatastrophe zu verhindern
also in paris hat man sich ein 1,5 grad
ziel gesetzt und den kompletten ausstieg
frei zu sein bis mitte des jahrhunderts
ist das überhaupt machbar ist das
realistisch
[Musik]
trump hat beschlossen dass die usa es
den klima vertrag aussteigen werden ist
er in der lage diese bewegung
[Musik]
aber in der usa leben viele klima
skeptiker die haben einen großen
rückhalt
sie reisen seit einigen jahren um die
welt und versuchen die leute zu
überzeugen
was ist für sie das beste mittel das
beste argument um ein klima skeptiker zu
überzeugen
[Musik]
sie haben gesagt mutter natur hätte das
beste argument
und sie spielte auch in ihren filmen und
19 film eine große rolle es gibt viele
bilder die mich an biblische szenen
erinnern apokalyptischen von überflutung
von funktioniert angst besser aus
hoffnung und die leute zu überzeugen
europa macht im moment weniger die
klimakrise sorgen als die
flüchtlingskrise und sie sagen im neuen
film die beiden dinge hängen zusammen
gerade was syrien angehängten der
klimawandel mit dem flüchtlingsstrom
zusammen
[Musik]
zum schluss eine kurze philosophische
frage meinte einmal der mensch so gerne
in der freien natur weil sie keine
meinung über die anziehungskraft der
natur
[Musik]
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
danke ja auch nächste woche spricht
meine kollegin barbara bleisch am
philosophischen stammtisch über den
klimawandel und fragt dürfen wir noch
fliegen
zum ersten mal findet der stammtisch vor
publikum in basel stadt das sollten sie
nicht verpassen
und jetzt gleich verlassen wir den
bereich der politik und tauchen ein in
die welt der literatur der poesie und
der liebe wir reisen nach paris in die
wahlheimat der deutsch französischen
schriftstellerin undine gründer kommen
sie also mit und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]